tu as 26 ans + wii alors tu trouves
d'une insuffisance hormonale qui a
stoppé sa croissance mais tu fait un
buzz énorme avec tes vidéos sur les
réseaux des suivis par plus de quatre
cent mille personnes
c'est ouf et tu fais de plus en plus des
interviews et à chaque fois c'est énorme
ce que tu fais regardez pas ce qui va
rester avec nous shakira ou jennifer
lopez a été la même chose quoi si on met
l'autre là on est l'autre l'a vraiment
le choix difficiles pour une nuit kim
kardashian ou bien c'est kim kardashian
j'ai même bien mais là elle parce qu
elles sont en lien et anna ya des trucs
la dga way cette commande la bonne
patate douce
il est exceptionnel
alors c'est vous alors le 1er février tu
as fait ta première grande scène à
l'olympia pour le concert de l'artiste
hiru outils débute une tournée qui
débute tuer tu débutes une tournée
mondiale le 27 mars prochain
tu es un grand fan de foot aussi merci
d'être avec nous dieu tu viens d'où un
maillon beau merci déjà le maire de
marans 17 parole dont deux qui fait
merci beaucoup je viens tout loi du
gabon d'accord dans la province de
discuter avec ce prêt pour moi je suis
venu pour heroes et tout est pour moi
aussi
oui pourrir vos louis février en
dévoilant ce soir c'est pour vous quand
la région
mais des troncs tetrobot toujours trop
merci d'être là et c'est une énorme star
une énorme star marion beaujolais il
fait un buzz incroyable
je veux que tu restes un petit peu avec
nous je sais que tu as tu aimes bien qu
ait dit ça c'est sûr
[Rires]
shetty c'est au style oui c'est mon
style et j'ai ma comme ailleurs on
s'adore ouais ah c'est réciproque
elle adore ça rigolait jeu là dedans tu
pourrais faire une histoire avec elle
une histoire
ouais d'amour mois que marion body de la
tendresse d'un time time of ten lancer
ou pas une fiancée ouais hein pas encore
parce que cela ne se présente pas sous
les lois d'accord mais tu n 9 ou pas
c'est une copine non je le sens pas je
chante je vais je vais quand même
enquêter là dessus
mayombo tu restes avec nous merci d'être
là et il est exceptionnel bouchraya
plaindrait de gens qui réagissent sur
les réseaux sociaux